the astros have proper valdez on the
mound getting a start tonight to also
get the start in the final game of this
home stand this season you can see that
his record is five and one he has seven
games he has started six of those seven
he has gone at least six innings or more
so runners at the corners after just two
pitches so good start for the a's as
matt olsen steps up hitting 283 with 20
homers
and there's a base hit into left field
olson beats the shift and it's one
nothing athletics
three hitters into the game
olson just rolled it into left field so
loriano scores and for matt olson that's
his first rbi in the last 14 games so
one away here's pinder
under the glove of carlos correa into
left center field for a hit elvis anders
is going to come around to score and the
a's lead two to nothing
is this fastball outside
watch correa up the middle
see how close he is to this ball dive
that saves a run keeps the bases loaded
but double plays in order instead the
a's go first to third score another run
and here's lowry who's batting 250 eight
home runs 36 rbis out of the stretch the
fish to lowry is swung on and hit the
center field hit well and back his straw
deep in the alley looking up it's off
the wall plays the carom olson has
scored and pinier's going to go to 30s
rounding third comes the plate to throw
and he's going to be out lowry winds up
at second one run scores
pinder is out on the relay and the
throat of the plate and the a's take a
three nothing lead well lowry drills the
ball off the wall center fielder straw
played the camera and played it back of
course olsen was going to score easily
from third base fence but pinder was out
at the plate on the relay by carlos
correa
one hopper and it's tough to run on
correa yeah he's got the one of the
strongest arms at the short stop
position double off the top of the wall
but the astros pick up their second out
of the inning as the third run crossed
the plate and the fourth run was gunned
down by the incredible armor carlos
correa ays with a three-nothing lead
over the astros bottom of the first
inning and chris passer with nice run
support in the first inning club gives
him three before he takes them out
making his 18 start nine and two on the
season here's jordan alvarez
jordan hits one high and deep to center
field you're done alvarez two-run home
run
a proud papa
left for a paternity leave in the
cleveland series comes back with a
two-run shot to center
really sweet spot out there in left
center field showing some big time power
he's on the attack really got a fastball
out over the plate he knew it
i'm not too sure ramon lariano knew it
as he tried to chase this ball through
the wall as it went up over his head and
out of here
420 feet later eight of ten home runs
allowed by chris bass that have been the
left-hand hitters it's three two a's
a rollicking start to this game top of
the second one out and two on
there's a base hit center field so elvis
anders does the job
lines a single right up the middle to
make it four to two yeah and again elvis
anders getting a fastball so these
which need to do answer right back at
the fastball up a little bit right back
up the middle so piscotty comes in to
score ace have eight hits in the game
now the fish to mat and it's on the way
by valdez and the 2-2 is a dribbler down
the first base line now rolling toward
the second basemal tuba throws to first
in time for the out but elvis scores and
the a's take a six to two lead so it's
six to two and the asus scored three
times in the first and here in the
second astros trail by four we're in the
bottom of the fourth inning get a couple
winners on for miles straw
up the middle bay said miles straw two
for two here comes jordan alvarez to
score it is now a six to three game on
the rbi single by mile straw
two out lightning for miles straw
alvarez's two run home run in the first
and it came with two outs
this rbi base hit off the bat of miles
straw comes with two outs
[Applause]
astros extending these innings by having
guys do great jobs at the plate getting
base hits and again
you get to see
jordan alvarez moving nicely into home
plate from second base chad pinder one
for two with an rbi single in the first
inning
a little tapper valdez off the mound in
a hurry looks the runner back to third
and makes the play nicely done by
fraumer valdez chapman will move to
second
one away in the inning
really was nicely done not an easy play
thromber left-handed pitcher falling off
towards that third base side allowed him
to get over there quickly but he did a
good job of checking the runner planting
the foot and making a strong throw
good job of taking his time and making
sure that out at first base
so now the infield comes in with jed
lowry who is two for two tonight olson
on third chapman on second with one out
ground ball towards third with the
infield in olson cannot score
toro makes the play
and that's a second out for fraber
valdez with matt olson staying at third
base here's sean murphy who has struck
out and grounded into a double play a
walk to olson a single to chapman to
start the inning frohmer had first and
third nobody out now he strikes out sean
murphy for the final out of the inning
great job by frambo working out a
trouble in the fifth we are halfway home
astros trails six to three runners on
first and third and jordan alvarez
will represent the tying run at the
plate
yard on high fly ball deep left field
ball game tied
the big man it's a three-run homerun
air yard on ties it at six baby jordan's
dad is having himself a game in his
first game back from paternity league
there's a new big poppy in town
you're done three for three
five runs batted in
two home runs
new team leader in rbis actually got a
fastball middle in but he did such a
good job of pulling the hands in early
and creating lag with that barrel and
all of a sudden the leverage of that
huge frame
shoots that ball out the other way
off the bat altuve knew it the fans
behind altuve on this tuesday night knew
it and they erupted two home runs three
hits and it's been a minute since we've
seen him hasn't pitched since late may
just off the il today guy at the plate
now frank schwendell hit a deep fly ball
as last time up trying to hold up he
goes around three pitch strikeout for
brian abreu nicely done first strikeout
since coming back